ulrike und daniel waren ja auch mal ein
paar in der serie ulrike wendel jetzt
noch so siehst deinen ehemaligen
serienpartner irgendwie fühlt sich das
gerade an
natürlich hat die geschichte damals
sicherlich auch dazu beigetragen dass
wir uns immer noch sehr herzlich
verbunden sind und wirklich freunde
geworden sind ja wir also kathrin und
lehrern das war für kathrin in der serie
die erste richtig große liebesgeschichte
muss man sagen und die ging auch eine
ganze zeit lang und sehr dramatisch mit
kind und entführung union also wahnsinn
was wir da alles erlebt haben und nach
wie vor also immer wenn es darum geht
wer könnte denn in zukunft mal wieder
ein paar werden werde ich also das wäre
nie verkehrt aber natürlich immer viele
neue möglichkeiten wo linke ich kann
mich sogar daran erinnern dass das
früher mal in der zeitung spekuliert
wurde ob ihr nicht sogar privat
irgendwie ein paar sein könnten obwohl
du ja zu der zeit auch schon verheiratet
was wäre denn zumindest oder daniel dän
typ gewesen wo du gesagt hat dass auch
der gefällt mir im privaten bereich
daher gefällt mir total gut verantworten
also absolute die also umso besser wenn
dann spekuliert wird auch dass auch
tomaten tvi sich fortsetzt dann ist es
glaubwürdig anderen
[Musik]